the corona virus pandemic has been slow
to reach Africa but the number of cases
is increasing fast as some governments
ramped up testing what is also happening
or if it's home breed efforts that would
be to tackle the pandemic when it hits
like at this Factory in Ghana where
workers are racing to reach a government
target of 3 million domestically
produced face masks by the end of April
I spoke to him a joke eh no he is the
co-chair of the afro champions
initiative the project is helping the
African Union mobilize resources to
tackle curve in nineteen he started by
telling me what lessons African learned
from the 2014 Ebola outbreak the Ebola
epidemic allowed us to learn two things
one they need for interdependence from
each other as a continent to be able to
mobilize our collective responsibility
towards each other by absorbing our
collective strengths you would recall
that even though it was just in Liberia
Guinea and Sierra Leone countries in
Africa initially started locking their
borders stopping flight from people
coming from the endemic region into
other parts of Africa the cases didn't
spread that much in Africa but he went
to Europe he went to America and it
alarmed the entire world people were
concerned about African to stopping
flights and he needed those corridors to
be open for girls to move in but Africa
echo was at the time Katy together and
in support with African Union mobilized
the African private sector to team up
with them and you recall there were a
lot of African multinational businesses
in Liberia Guinea and Sierra Leone what
we shut down
we learned that this was something that
the African governments couldn't do
alone so private sector came together
mobilize resources send doctors
volunteer doctors from daya Bay I mean
from other parts of the continent to go
to Liberia Guinea in Sierra Leone and as
a consequence we saw that we were able
to with the support of international
partners eradicate Ebola so that
collective responsibility was important
it also helped the continent change the
way it looked at things as far as
immigration and and and and movement of
people I mean we still had a number of
countries that still especially the hub
countries that had a lot of traffic that
still kept checking temperatures for
people who were coming into the country
that has sanitizers at the airport for
people to clean your hands and things
like that and it changed the way we saw
hygiene practices particularly in
airports where we are traffic I had huge
traffic's of people coming through but
the biggest lesson for us was the
public/private partnership that came as
a result of this and that's what
inspired you know the creation of our
champions which which I currently
co-chair right so as I mentioned in the
beginning of this conversation you've
been tasked with assisting African Union
in mobilizing resources to tackle urban
19 what exactly are you doing so first
was to reach back to the private sector
networks that were pretty much involved
in the Ebola epidemic to say here were
here we are again we have another
epidemic at hand we were also very
pretty instrumental in pushing has in
supporting the heads of states in their
wisdom to set up on African CDC because
we thought that it was important to have
an African center for disease and
control that can sort of coordinate the
continental efforts that is necessary to
fighting epidemics of this nature when
they do come so our main responsibility
is to provide mobilize resources first
financial resources to support African
Union fund that has been set up to
mobilize support to buy you know the to
do the bulk procurements that are
continuing needs because it's difficult
for countries on your own in these days
where different people are procuring
facemasks PPEs protective equipment
ventilators and all of the things that
we need to test it so getting those
resources to a consolidated fund that
would be able to procure those resources
on behalf of the continent but also
getting the personnel necessarily you
know the volunteer support because you
could have all these equipment and not
have the personnel to use them
so getting the doctors the paramedics
the nurses and all of these human
resources that CDC needs to deploy into
areas of need you know it's been said
that Africa is at the ports of the
mountain and correct me if I'm wrong in
terms of what stage we're at in this in
this pandemic but what is your prognosis
so to say what should Africans be
bracing for we've seen this virus has
done in countries like Italy we've seen
what it's done and is doing in the
United States what is the inevitable for
the continent
I want to be optimistic and say that yes
apricot caught this at the tail end and
and and the numbers were generated so
far since the lock downs that have been
done in number of countries and not even
enough to suggest we've done probably
about three hundred thousand tests so
far in the entire continent but we
looked at the date that we generated so
far is still too little to be able to
predict what will happen even in the
advanced countries where they collected
a lot of data even some of the
projections in terms of their modeling
as it relates to things like the number
of deaths as you see when they thought
they were going to have more deaths
didn't they didn't quite have those
heads and when they didn't expect they
had a lot more deaths like you saw in
Italy and other places but then you see
Portugal and other places that really
didn't register the kind of dead so one
of the things that I think the country
the continent has done is we've been
able to shut up all this very quickly we
didn't get a mass transportation of
people into the continent with the
barrels like other people's and even if
we did the past two months we haven't
seen people falling down and dying we
haven't seen a hospital's flooding and
most of the data we collected so far
shows that significant early people even
what I even positive are asymptomatic
and it's not really going into the
vulnerable population so if you ask what
you embracing for stay unknown we don't
know what we should do is we should get
more and more people tested as much as
possible and which is why every
champions supports and has partnered the
African Union CDC again in this pact
you know partnership towards getting
people tracked traced and tested you
know to be able to get at least a
million people tested within the next
four weeks 10 million people tested
within the next six weeks and create the
given numbers that will help us
understand what we're dealing with so I
don't really think that within a
situation where we're gonna that's my
personal view that we're going to be
seeing millions of people but that's not
to say that we should let our got off
no we should continue to maintain all
the standards of hygiene the protocols
under which you know we can prevent the
disease because you cannot afford to
have our hospitals blood it will not be
able to have the personnel the doctors
the name of IC used to be able to deal
with this pandemic and as much as
possible focus on the primary health
care needs get people identify track
traced tested and then isolated for
treatment and and and and embrace for
what I mean more concerned about is the
economic aspects you know of this pond
ending the socio-economic aspects of
this pond ma that is disrupting you know
you know people's daily lives their
daily needs the resources they need to
be able to feed their families and that
for me is something I'm more concerned
about from in terms of the hunger
endemic as opposed to the health endemic
right now and that would be do you have
specifics on the content or maybe
regions that you you think are
particularly most vulnerable to this
maybe it's because they have their more
I will help you to travel happens at
some point or is it an issue of the
countries that have the weaker health
systems mostly again it's it's all
speculative and is a roll of a dice I
mean we see countries that have huge
traffic like Ghana South Africa North
African countries are the ones that seem
to have the highest numbers so far but
you also see Cameroon that necessarily
doesn't it's not a heart per se and the
N numbers are peaking you've seen
countries that have done lock downs and
I've done lots of testing and countries
that have been really down lock downs
but I also do more tests in their
countries that have done lock downs and
you've seen countries that I really
haven't done lock down so it's still
very very hard to tell
we saw le gates the data generated so
far doesn't tell much but the little
information we've guarded you know in
our campaign is that whatever whatever
happening and whatever we've missed and
whatever advantages we have it still
doesn't negate the fact that
we should test more so as much as
opposed to what we need to get people
testing and we feel that in language the
African continent of free trade area
prospect where we want to have a common
market which means we need to move
people across the board we need to move
Goods this is the more reason why the
continent shall come together and let
the strong countries help the vulnerable
ones the countries that have stronger
health systems their strong countries
that have strong public health
institutions but the countries also who
are public health institutions may not
necessarily have the capacity to produce
the basic things that you need so that
we have to look at the continent in
totality and say what different regions
of the continent hats have that others
don't have and how do we tap into each
other's collective strengths to be able
to solve this especially when the people
would normally go through the countries
that would normally go to for help and
support have to put the oxygen masks on
their faces first before they can even
think about us and that's the that's
what every champion is championing in
fact we've got people in Egypt for
example that are producing PBS South
Africa that are sending ventilators we
have Kenyans who are producing 100,000
peepees a day they've had to improvise
and come up with a medical grade version
of a PPE Ghana's manufacturing peepees
Morocco but we cannot have export
restrictions on our products we should
treat Africa's a domestic market and
this again pushes the need for us to now
use the continent of free trade as a
weapon
so also defeating the cove in nineteen
lastly just for targets
yourself what would you consider a
victory over this pandemic if you are
any conflict based on the polls or other
thing you've said well as you assess the
African Union in mobilizing resources to
tackle covert 19 well as much as
possible if you are able to limit as
money infections as possible limits
infections okay limit social harm and
limit deaths if we can look at and these
are the pillars that underpin the
coordinated continental air for that the
African Union is driving
hñ business partnered with if we can
save lives and get to a point where we
are not losing incalculable losses of
people dying if we can sort of socially
work together to ensure that we are not
endangering each other that everybody's
on informed and involved
we're not stigmatizing people and who
are who are infected and that we tap
into a communal strengths which is what
we have as Africans you know to inform
identify people who have it get
everybody tested as many people who can
get tested then that would be victory
because that will give us the data we
need to ensure that we can all open our
borders we cannot begin to move freely
we can begin to trade and do the things
that are the lifeblood for livelihood
which is just moving Goods and people
around that would be successful